bonjour à tous
merci de m'accueillir je suis déjà passé
par
et à
et je ne vous
aujourd'hui je suis vraiment du mauvais
côté de l'amphi j'ai étudié il ya dix
ans maintenant dans cette université le
management et j'essaie de réfléchir à ça
pourquoi est ce que j'ai voulu étudier
le management et vous tient pour est ce
que vous êtes là prenez 5 secondes pour
réfléchir à ça avec un peu de recul je
pense que j'ai voulu étudier le
management pour plusieurs raisons
d'abord pour entrer dans une entreprise
avec un statut reconnu avec des
responsabilités et des enjeux ou alors
non peut-être un truc pas trop fatiguant
et bien payé alors je suis là trois ans
de ma vie à apprendre plein de choses et
gestion de ressources humaines la
finance la gestion de projet le droit la
négociation tout ça trois ans à préparer
l'étape d'après comme vous mon premier
job comme beaucoup d'autres étudiants je
suis devenu développeurs de logiciels
dans une grosse boîte
fini le management définit la gestion de
quoi que ce soit comme me l'a dit un
jour 1a recruteurs de talent tu
comprends dans un fast food on va
d'abord commencer par faire des frites
avant de tenir la caisse trois ans de ma
vie à apprendre tout ça pour rien
alors on prend ses marques on monte
petit à petit en compétences ont fini
par devenir un développeur potable et
parfois correct sur les bons jours et un
jour arrive ce jour merveilleux ce jour
où ton chef tout convoque et tu te dis
que tu fait du super travail que tu es
vraiment un bon développeur et du coup
tu vas devenir chef de projet ça y est
on y est c'est marrant mais peu importe
le parcours qu'on aurait pu avoir les
étapes sont les mêmes pour tous d'abord
tu développes et si tu es bon tu vas
devenir chef de projet situé encore bon
tu deviendras manager si curieux non
pourquoi si je suis bon lorsque je fais
on va me demander de faire autre chose
et si finalement j'ai aimé ça si
finalement j'aimais être développeur
pourquoi est ce que j'aurai besoin de
changer
certains appelleront ça une évolution de
carrière moi je pense qu'il faut pas
confondre une évolution voulue et
accompagner et d'un autre côté donné les
clés d'une ferrari à un gosse de 6 ans
et lui demander d'aller conduire
on va revenir à mon histoire
quelques années gérer mes projets mon
équipe ont permis de voir l'entreprise
que je pensais connaître de manière
complètement différente
on passe le plus clair de son temps en
réunion et en travail de moins en moins
on peut se dire que tout ça est normal
si finalement le reste le plus grand
nombre de l'entreprise est encore
consacrée aux réalisations aux choses
qu'on de la vraie valeur
sauf que quand on regarde réellement les
choses et qu'on se rend compte qu'on est
une bonne douzaine à se bagarrer dans
des réunions sans fin pour essayer de
comprendre sur quoi trois ou quatre
personnes vont travailler on se dit
qu'on a peut-être atteint des sommets et
le pire c'est que les gens les mieux
payés dans la société sont ceux qui vont
passer leur temps en réunion a essayé de
faire valoir ce pour quoi ils sont payés
j'ai donc décidé de changer de métier je
suis devenu coach s'est pas fait du jour
au lendemain j'ai choisi d'aller voir
autre chose parce que je me suis dit que
ses petits travers kim avait un petit
peu chatouiller venaient d'autres choses
et que d'autres entreprises pouvaient
être différente donc j'accompagne
maintenant d'autres organisations avec
d'autres managers et je peux vous
rassurer tous ses petits travers qu'on a
pu voir dans mon expérience passée sont
en fait par fermant parfaitement normal
et tout à fait répandu mais qu'est ce
qui cloche alors les organisations se
transforme
les grands projets sont chahutés par les
aléas du marché et par les innovations
de rupture les petites start up sont
maintenant plus virulente que les grands
concurrents d'autres froid donc
l'entreprise doit s'adapter
elle change s'est produit à change ses
services mais pas que elle doit aussi
changer la façon dont elle travaille et
son organisation
ça les dirigeants l'ont bien compris
donc ils vont s'accompagner de grandes
équipes de transformation qui vont faire
plus ou moins deux des grands leaders
inspirants que tout le monde attend et
de l'autre côté de l'échelle il ya les
équipes
elle change elle aussi elle voit défiler
les nouvelles méthodes de travail plus
vite que des collections de
prêt-à-porter pas le temps d'en essayer
lui que la nouvelle est déjà là
télétravail flex office équipe multi
site international autonome et auto
organisées tout le monde rêve de beauce
et danser dans ces entreprises qui ont
dix ans d'avancé sur leurs temps où on
travaille en basket dans un hamac en
couleur avec un smoothie à l'erreur sauf
qu'on a oublié quelqu'un dans le
portrait on a oublié les managers à
différents niveaux avec différentes
responsabilités
c'est eux qui vont transformer les
grandes ambitions de l'entreprise en
quelque chose de concret qui arrivera
vraiment pour aller un petit peu plus
loin j'ai fait quelques recherches
comme vous je me suis pas trop foulé je
suis allé sur internet et et on lit que
le management c'est l'art de mettre les
moyens humains et les moyens matériels
d'une entreprise à destination de ses
objectifs du coup j'ai lu des livres
fait exister
les plus anciens livres considère le
management comme un maillon essentiel de
l'entreprise le manager est là pour
penser à la place de ces ouvriers parce
qu'ils sont pas capables de le faire
le manager ne doit pas comprendre le
métier pour lequel ces ouvriers
travaillent parce qu'il pourrait se
rendre compte que de nouvelles
augmentations de cadences sont pas
possibles
mais si on lit les textes plus récents
c'est beaucoup moins sympa on considère
le management comme le plus haut niveau
d'incompétence dans les entreprises
parce que plus on manage et moi on fait
et moins on fait moins et pertinents
lorsqu'on accompagne des entreprises
comme je fais on rencontre différents
styles de management
ces managers ont tout savoir des leurs
styles et pour vous faire gagner un peu
de temps je vous ai fait une petite
compilation
je leur ai donné des noms pour vous
aider à les retenir le premier c'est le
passe-plat le passe-plat l a bien
compris comment ça marche une entreprise
tels objectifs sont les objectifs de ton
chef c'est facile et si tu y arrives
tout le monde est content alors comment
ça se passe dans l'arène je vais vous
donner un exemple un vrai une entreprise
cherche à économiser sur ses coûts de
développement
elle va donc essayer de mettre 10% de
ses effectifs à l'étranger
ça peut se comprendre que font les
basques la lente reprise
elle va donner cet objectif au pass
plein au chef qui va donner sa sont sous
passe plat qui aura pour objectif 10% de
son ca de ton identité à l'étranger qui
fera de même à l'étagé en dessous 10% de
ton service à l'étranger qui fera de
même au niveau des équipes 10% de
tourner équipe à l'étranger
c'est facile sauf qu'on se retrouve dans
ce genre de cas avec un mec tout seul
à l'autre bout du monde qui attend
derrière un téléphone qu'une équipe qui
ne connaît pas lui donne un travail pour
lequel il sait pas forcément comment s'y
prendre peut-être qu'à management un
petit peu différent aurait pu s'y
prendre différemment est constitué de
vraie équipe
même à l'autre bout du monde avec un
vrai but est de vraies ambitions
le deuxième profil deuxième profil c'est
le poilu lui l'a fait la guerre et à 100
ans
et en plus il a gagné donc il faut bien
croire que ce qu'il a fait à l'époque
c'est la bonne méthode
pas question de changer quoi que ce soit
et si jamais il ya des problèmes
faisons toujours plus de la même chose
comme ça on aura toujours plus du même
résultat
le changement peut venir d'en haut ou
d'en dessous
il se battra bec et ongles pour ne rien
changer troisième profil le sénateur le
sénateur il a bien compris comment
marche une entreprise
il a mis des années à arriver là hélas
bien l'intention de garder sa place
pour lui tout est politique alors il se
réunit avec d'autres sénateurs prend
parfois conscience des vrais problèmes
que ce soit des problèmes de
collaboration entre services ou même de
vrais besoins de réorganisation
mais la politique c'est important on
doit pas montrer les choses qui vont pas
parce qu'on pourrait perdre sa place
donc on ne met pas en avant les vrais
problèmes on évite d'être transparent et
ont fini par prendre des décisions tiède
avec pas de réelles actions derrière
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que beaucoup de
gens se demandent où sont les sénateurs
qu'est ce qu'ils font
4e profil le pilote le pilote il va vite
et le pilote il va loin
le dirige ses équipes avec des tableaux
de bord extrêmement compliqué parce que
pour lui les chiffres c'est la clé les
chiffres ces pratiques parce que ça veut
tout dire
on peut aussi leur faire dire ce qu'on
veut alors on en met partout on va
demander aux équipes d'en faire toujours
plus mais c'est pour ça qu'on va se
retrouver avec des gens qui passent une
demi journée par semaine a essayé de
décrire ce sur quoi ils ont travaillé à
la demi heure près foire - ça ça dure
qu'un temps les gens comprennent les
chiffres se rendre compte que ça ce
pirate et qu'on va faire distribuer je
vais arrêter ici
le descriptif des pratiques de des
pratiques peu glorieuses et je passais
très peu de temps sur d'autres profils
tels que le prof qui est persuadé qu'il
a toutes les réponses qui distribuera
les tâches à tout le monde et donnera
des notes en fin d'année ou alors
l'oncle picsou qui pensent que l'argent
c'est tout et qui comprendra pas
pourquoi son équipe reste toujours aussi
peu motivés après avoir augmenté tout le
monde et distribuer des primes
certains reconnaîtront ici des figures
un peu familière mais ne serions pas de
nous mêmes caché derrière ce type de
comportement ce n'est pas réservé à des
élites mais chacun de nous plus ou moins
souvent et avec plus ou moins de
virulence sommes un peu caché derrière
ses comportements
la façon dont nous travaillons et la
façon dont les entreprises se sont
constitués s'est fait sur des siècles
entier la compréhension de l'entreprise
et de leur rôle dépasse beaucoup d'entre
nous et et surtout on n'a pas le toit
j'ai mon chef sur le dos tu crois que
j'ai que ça à [ __ ] de penser à ça et
non on n'a pas le temps on n'a pas le
temps parce qu'on est rentré dans cette
routine
on a pris nos marques et maintenant on
travaille comme ça on se dit qu'on
changera pas le monde et c'est normal
pourquoi est ce que tout cela arrive
d'abord par manque de confiance on voit
tous l'entreprise comme une sorte de
totem géant sur lequel il faut essayer
de s'élever le plus haut possible
il ya qu'à voir la façon dont on parle
démarré en bas de l'échelle
gravir les échelons top management sauf
que sur cette échelle
il n'y a pas de place pour la confiance
pourquoi est ce que je fais confiance à
mes collègues
vu qu'on est en train de briller la même
place au dessus de nous pourquoi est ce
que je fais confiance à mon chef
parce que je veux lui dire que tout va
bien et je comprends à peine les
objectifs qui me donne et moi dans tout
ça est ce que mes équipes me font
confiance
est ce que je leur donne confiance quand
je leur distribuer le travail et que je
surveille ce sur quoi chacun travaille
et ce que je crée de la confiance
finalement ce que j'ai besoin de faire
ça est-ce que je risquerais pas de
perdre ma place si les choses changent
tout ça est accéléré par une culture qui
donne aucun droit à l'erreur
on a été élevé comme ça à l'école si
j'ai de mauvaises notes
mes parents me disent lutte en
entreprise c'est exactement pareil
si je fais des erreurs c'est mal et au
manager me dispute
pourquoi je prendrais des risques il est
important de commencer par prendre
conscience de ces choses là c'est la
première étape vers le changement et les
choses changent les choses changent
parce que des entreprises vont arriver
aller au delà de ces dysfonctionnements
comment ils s'y prennent d'abord envoyé
à l'entreprise d'une manière totalement
différente
on ne va pas chercher à pousser les gens
vers de l'encadrement ou du management
on va plutôt reconnaître les expertises
de chacun et les voir de manière
différente reconnaître l'expertisé c'est
valoriser les gens se leur faire
comprendre que le domaine dans lequel
ils sont bons a de la valeur pour
l'entreprise
et ces gens là vont sentir
responsabiliser vont faire part de leurs
compétences à tout le monde et sont bien
plus efficaces dans leur travail
pourtant ça empêche pas d'aller vers du
management et le rôle de manager il
évolue lui aussi les volumes parce que
le manager est là pour créer un
environnement qui permettra à ces
équipes d'être autonome et de
s'auto-organiser comment ils s'y
prennent de plusieurs manières
la première c'est la délégation observer
la façon dont les décisions se prennent
dans une entreprise fait un premier pas
pour avancer
confier des décisions au plus près de
l'action va permettre de responsabiliser
les gens de leur faire comprendre que
leur décision a de l'importance et le
deuxième avantage c'est que ça rend
l'entreprise beaucoup plus réactive
si on limite les intermédiaires le
deuxième point c'est la motivation
beaucoup pensent que le pouvoir et la
rémunération ça fait tout sauf que c'est
pas le cas
les gens fonctionnent tous différemment
et certains sont motivés par autre chose
la liberté l'honneur l'ordre avoir un
but tout ça ça constitue la diversité
d'une équipe et à un manager qui sait
s'occuper de ça et le prendre en compte
rires à des vraies relations à
l'intérieur de son équipe le dernier
point c'est le droit à l'erreur
le droit à l'erreur c'est fondamental
c'est quelque chose qui va permettre de
créer un environnement sain dans lequel
chacun peut se lancer expérimenté sans
avoir peur qu'on lui tombe dessus parce
qu'il aura fait mal les choses créer un
environnement sain responsabilise les
gens et on voit certaines entreprises
qui célèbre les erreurs parce que si
négatif que ça puisse paraître une
erreur c'est un apprentissage
tout ceci contribue à la création d'un
environnement positif parce que
finalement c'est ça le rôle de manager
je crois pas à ces théories fumantes qui
disent qu'un manager doit être ce leader
inspirés et inspirants qui n'a qu'à
lever le doigt pour rallier tout le
monde a sa vision un manager c'est un
être humain comme tout le monde
parfois poilus parfois pilotes il fera
des erreurs et il sort allait
reconnaître mais le vrai but du manager
est de créer cet environnement positif
pour que chacun puisse trouver la
meilleure place possible dans une
organisation et maintenant vous vous
demandez comment va plus loin en allant
s'inspirer des autres et en poursuivant
l'effort quelques pionniers ont décidé
de changer la façon dont on travaille de
percevoir l'organisation et les
relations de manière différente
s'inspirer de ces choses là et les
expérimentés à tous les niveaux
permettra de changer le monde du travail
et je ne se feront pas en deux jours ni
même en deux mois ça prendra plusieurs
années
mais le changement le plus important
il est devant nous le changement le plus
important il est devant moi c'est les
nouvelles générations qui vont changer
la façon de comprendre l'entreprise
c'est vous et tous les autres futurs
professionnels qui intégreront les
entreprises qui vont changer le monde du
travail
prenez conscience de ça les entreprises
dans lesquelles vous allez rentrer vous
aura un oeil neuf
cet oeil neuf personne ne peut le payer
après 10 ou 15 ans de boîte ou alors au
coude un vrai travail de fond comprenez
que le changement de mentalité passera
par votre discernement et dans les
décisions vous prendrez quand vous serez
à de haut niveau comprenez aussi que
votre opinion a de la valeur et vous
devez la faire valoir dans le respect de
chacun bien sûr comprenez que vous
n'avez pas à rentrer dans le moule c'est
peut-être pas à vous de changer que
c'est pas parce qu'on a toujours fait
comme ça que c'est la bonne méthode
inspirez-vous du monde professionnel
dans lesquels vous allez rentrer essayer
d'en voir les choses qui fonctionnent
mais essayez de voir aussi leurs limites
puis créer l'environnement dans lequel
vous avant
le monde du travail est l'endroit dans
lequel vous allez passer le plus clair
de votre vie vous allez y passer plus de
temps qu'avec vos amis votre famille
alors ne fait aucune concession
merci pour votre attention et si je suis
ici du mauvais côté du l'amphi c'est
pour vous rappeler que vous n'êtes
peut-être pas fait pour faire des frites
merci
[Applaudissements]